so listen as a co-founder entrepreneur
Oscar millions of dollars on attorneys
on CPAs on you know engineers on
consultants a lot and I have a lot of
horror stories oh my gosh I got a lot of
horror stories and a lot of experience
and so moving on after all of these
experiences when I hire consultants
attorneys accountants engineers any of
these my conversations are whole
different conversation then it was 10
years ago when I hired I'm not having to
call what I was doing so today I'm gonna
give you 10 questions you need to ask
every consultant before you hired them
[Music]
before I share with you the 10 questions
I want to give you a story of what
happened recently when this lady came in
and we were sitting there with all our
executives and a boardroom and she's
sitting to my right and and and one of
our guys like here's what we're hiring
her because of this and very credible
guy in our company and so here's she
started talking about here's what I can
do for you here's what and then the
moment she got into it this is what you
need this is what you need this is what
you need I said and she said so here's
what I can and I started asking all
these questions and she started kind of
barking a little bit getting a little
nervous
I said timeout I said I'm Hank Todd you
can sit in this number you're gonna be
hearing about what we need
I said team we don't need her first
she's third we have other issues to
address before we hire her I thank you
so much for your time can you give us a
few minutes wait outside now pretty much
verbatim that's how the meeting went I
had her step outside and I spoke to my
crew and I said look before we hire her
there's a few issues we have before we
hire a consultant what is it we don't
even have a specific outcome of what
we're trying to do before we hire this
person so we got to get clear on our
outcome before hiring the consultant why
are we doing this what questions are we
trying to get answer because if you
don't have that in place they're gonna
triple the workload oh you also don't
have this because their job is to
constantly throw our problems oh my gosh
this is a very bad problem because 73.8%
of companies that hire did that and you
know they throw these numbers out there
you know my gosh panic fear this is
terrible you know it causes big
companies go out of business that's
their job to do that right so that's
what they do impose fear here's how I
can help it's a very simple hey Gillian
you know whatever you want to call it
tactic that
and a lot of these guys do that job
attorneys if you don't get this wording
right you could get sued and I've seen
companies go out of business you're
gonna hear that a lot as a co-founder
and it puts so much fear in you relax
it's okay unless if you have a crisis
it's a different story but you want to
be an anticipation preparation game most
important thing before hiring a
consultant cpa attorney any of these
guys engineers you've got to get very
very crystal clear on what you want even
before asking these ten questions you
got to get clear what you want so if you
have that in place then let's get into
the ten questions so the first question
I ask is listen before you give us
advice
what made you an expert to be able to
give us advice on what we need to do
when we pay you money for the advice
what was it where did you work at what
did you learn what have you seen what
have you built how high did you move up
in your career before you chose to
become a consultant because sometimes
there's different kinds of consultants
there's those consultants who work at a
company for a while they burn out they
don't want a w-2 they just choose to be
1099 and they want to do some work on
the side and be free I literally had a
consultant that he became a consultant
because he wants to sale and that's all
he wants to do so he takes a few clients
per year it doesn't want to be a
millionaire he's good with that there's
also some consultants because they got
fired because they were not the best of
employees and it went through a lot of
different companies so then they become
consultants these are the ones you're
trying to filter out and it are those
consultants that are actually very very
good at what they do and these are the
guys that are workers they're gonna do
their part and you're gonna earn their
money when they work with you you're
trying to find them so I asked that
question to see where their credibility
comes from to give me advice and our
team advice about what we need to do
next so the second question is why did
you become a consultant and I want to
hear clues I want to hear why they
became that well I became because I saw
so many different companies being taken
advantage of and I wanted to find that I
said give me some stories like whatever
they say whatever answer they give so
many times SEOs and entrepreneurs or
executives that are about to hire
because sometimes your CFO CEO CEO or
CMO you're hiring a consultant from
sometimes even the CEO is not involved
but sometimes you ask that question it's
a good question to ask they give a
respond you don't respond back then you
don't have a real answer you don't have
all the details
so you give that question they give
their answer then you go deeper and say
why tell me more why is that how about
this what happened here you've got to go
deeper to see if there's any areas where
you're like ah no way in the world we're
gonna spend a hundred eighty thousand
dollars on you in my mind boom checked
off I don't even need to go to the rest
of the questions because I'm clear this
is just not gonna work out or wow that's
so impressive you worked here can you
show me story there's there yet
yes very impressed so some things will
either lead you to being a little bit
worried yourself or some things you'll
go Danny like but it's pretty impressive
I want to go more so question number
three is asking them about their
experience with a company like ours or
an issue that you're facing what kind of
success have you here trying to solve
this following issue or address the
final request that we have for you right
now why do you ask that question because
sometimes consultants may have had
success with a company trying to solve
an issue that has nothing to do with the
issue trying to solve it's almost like
go to a dermatologist trying to ask
about your lungs which you need to sit
with maybe a pulmonologist or a layering
different field right both are doctors
but their specialty is a different place
the same goes with consultant a
consultant isn't good at every aspect of
the company's problems that you're
facing so you ask specifically this is
what we're trying to solve you were
recommended to us by this place and we
would like to know tell us one specific
expertise you had in solving this issue
if they have it ask us for multiple
different stories and let them see what
they can tell you about it number four
tell me about your more success most
successful client you've ever had what
do you mean who's your most successful
client you've ever had and they're gonna
take their story on that this client
you're not for working meet again
eighty-three percent retention they'll
throw some numbers with you none of it
you can measure because anytime you say
can I how do you measure that number and
can I see data on that while I have an
NDA sound with the company I can't
really show you that's typically where
it's gonna go to but it's very easy if
they say that you're hoping to get great
clients three good stories of clients
then you ask can I call them yeah sure
they're either gonna give you the answer
sure you can call them or well there's
some you know legal stuff that we can't
contact them because of director okay
that's a red flag to me
but if they'll tell you short and then
who can I call can I speak to the CEO
can I speak to the CFO who was it
yeah no problem and then you go do your
research on who you callin credibility
again you're gonna go out and find that
who it is you're hoping they're right
you're not trying to be like a detective
to see if they're wrong you are hoping
they're right but at the same time you
have to realize you got to do the
follow-up and do your own due diligence
to see what they say about the
experience and see if the numbers that
they gave is close and they'll verify to
say yes it was 83% then you got to do a
little little bit of like work on your
end so then the follow-up questions a
tough one to ask most co-founders have a
hard time asking this question or even
executives have a hard time asking this
question because it's kind of a little
bit offensive here's what the question
is and you open it up preface it very
easily listen we've been in business for
a while and we've been doing this a lot
of things we do right but God knows
we've done a lot of things wrong that
didn't work out for us so having said
that what were the three clients that
you had that ended up becoming a failure
that the results weren't met what were
they and why and let them tell the story
and sometimes they'll tell the story
guaranteed you can hear one the stores
being this way here's how the story goes
well the CEO wasn't willing to take the
counsel that I gave him and because of
that electric that that that that one of
the stories they tell is going to be
this I'm not interested in that story
because I do know what it is for have a
stubborn C or stubborn executive with
all that other stuff that they don't
want any kind of counsel that's very
common the story I want to hear about is
what they did wrong that they could have
done differently now what am I looking
for
you know what's crazy about what I'm
looking for just the fact that they're
not afraid of telling the truth gives me
trust that I can do business with them
it's amazing just the fact that they'd
sell something like this not unlikely
there was this one client that we had
and here's what we did and we didn't do
the right work who should have gone this
row but we went this rod and it didn't
end up working out for us with that
client we like them a lot we were really
hoping to come through but it didn't
happen I was about seven years ago and
here's what we learned from it what we
learned from it is the fact that that
that defense or the next client that we
faced that had the similar issue when we
made that decision this one we did it
this one the results ended up being this
way and I have to tell you even though
that was a bad mistake I'm so glad that
we went through because of it it made us
a bit of a consultant that a see what
I'm saying see that approach I'm looking
for that that's all I'm looking for but
if the consultant the attorney the
engineer the whoever you're hiring the
accountant cannot tell you
a bad experience that they had were
their fault it was their fault that they
did then you're dealing with an
organization that whatever you do is
gonna be your fault your fault your form
that they're not gonna take
responsibility and I don't typically do
business with people like that I want to
know how somebody that's made mistakes
that they're willing to say here's a
mistake I made here's what we learned
from it here's how we're improving it's
not gonna happen to you so then the last
question within that part it's still on
the same question is can I call the CEO
and if they say yes checkmark they're so
brave most of the time I won't even call
them I'm just trying to see how brave
they are that if I can't call this yo
they say yes no problem credibility goes
to the roof with me so the next three
questions is all about accountability on
how to hold them accountable and the one
question I ask is how do we measure
success with you let me explain to what
I mean by this John Mary Johnson
consulting firm say we're done with the
project I'm very happy I tell the world
about it I go online whatever site it is
they're you I'm gonna write a review and
I tell them how amazing you are so you
get more business because I want more
SEOs and founders to know consultants
like you that say what they're gonna do
and they come through everybody wants to
know but what do we also do to prevent
my frustration our team's frustration of
saying I want to go write a review
because I think other people need to
know how you didn't come through and so
you're held accountable for other seals
and founders don't waste their
hard-earned money on a project that
didn't come through so how do we measure
success with you and then they'll tell
you whatever they're gonna tell you then
it leads me to the next part which is
give me it give me a time frame say we
move on here give me timeframe on what
you think is gonna be taking place give
me one that we're gonna have this part
on phase 1 phase 2 phase 3 phase 4 and
maybe they'll say we need more time to
put this together for you no problem and
again that's another phase for them to
have to come back to you with what
they're gonna be doing yes here's what I
think the time frame is gonna be for
this this this this that perfect that
goes to the next question the next
question for me is what kind of updates
should we be expecting time frame wise
are we getting daily updates weekly
updates monthly updates and they may say
in the first month you will get daily
updates but month two you're gonna get
weekly updates and month three is gonna
be a biweekly update because as we're
getting to the completion whatever the
timeline is 12 month product right now
we're doing a IT projects that's
probably a 12 month project 13 month
project and we start it's a
multi-million dollar project that may be
a different
and then another project that were
working on that's only a three hundred
thousand dollar project and that's gonna
take two months to do but the structure
on that's gonna be different but I still
want to get updates I'm all about
updates it's like the last thing you
want is last week three months there but
then they give you an update and seventy
two things you never wanted anyways they
waste the time on it it's not a way to
do so pure accountability right up front
what kind of updates are we going to be
getting from you so we know what's being
worked on and we can see what's being
worked on with us hiring you
okay so point number nine is a little
bit technical and depending on the size
of the business you got you may
experience this you may not experience
it but regardless of what it is this is
something you ought to know so so many
times when you start a project the team
that starts with you doesn't end with
you so we started a project that the
engineer that we were communicating with
that we spend a hundred hours talking to
the two engineers they are no longer
there so they were not hired to fulfill
the project from the beginning to the
end so they brought total engineers and
then I had to re-explain and wasted our
time double the work very frustrating
but because we didn't negotiate properly
from the beginning that's what happened
there so now this is how I negotiate now
I asked once they're telling me who it
is that the electrical were agreeing to
do in this thing I want to meet the
entire team that's gonna be working on
this project from the beginning to the
end and here's what I want to know Bobby
Johnny Mary whatever consulting firm it
is what do I need to get from you
knowing that they're gonna begin the
project and they're gonna end this
project well I don't have to explain
myself multiple times and it's a very
interesting answer they'll give you it
can be a very different well we don't
know because it's a world of engineering
people change so it's not necessarily
the case if it's an hourly project give
to somebody and they're working on it
from beginning to the end that means
they're on that project beginning to the
end that's my problem what's gonna
happen over here well we don't normally
do this because we can't really predict
the future
I also normally don't cut mostly
seven-figure checks so do you want the
seven-figure check board so you got to
tell me if you want the business great
if you don't I need to know that's a
risk for me well no problem what if we
were able to make that happen for you
that's a very big priority for me okay
let us see what they can do that's the
homework they need to be doing right
then as you get closer to saying yes we
want to do this I want to meet the team
what do you mean I want to meet
everybody that's gonna be working on my
project you wanna meet
I want to meet everybody so say they're
local I literally want every one of them
in my board room so they'll come in and
it'll be 20 of them sitting right there
or 8 of them or 7 of more 11 of them
here's who's gonna be on the team great
so this person that person this person
this one yes this person is gonna be
phase 1 phase 2 this person is gonna be
phase 2 phase 3 phase 1 person is gonna
be out because we won't need them
anymore cuz the specialty is gonna be
this but phase one's gonna show for
phase 4 and how am I gonna make sure
that phase one's gonna be here for us so
John tell me how long you been with the
company how long you been with this law
firm how long given with this consulting
firm seven years
great three months two months five
months red flag red flag red flag all of
it so again I'm trying to give you some
blind spots that you may not have that
cost me Millions so I hope you don't
make that same millions of dollars
yourself but that's one of the questions
I ask before we get into the last
question which is the question most
people on ask first I don't care about
asking this question first I asked this
question last and guess what it has to
do with money cost structure how are we
breaking us down so then they give me a
bit here's what I think is gonna take
but here's how I ask for it a bit ready
okay here's how I ask for a bit I don't
say how much is this gonna cost this is
what I tell them John Bobby
Mary Johnson consulting firm I want you
to know my philosophy I don't like to go
back-and-forth negotiating here's why I
am going to get two other bids outside
of you okay and I know all the people in
your world I'm gonna get two more bids
outside of you I want to make sure you
don't try to pull off I'm not saying
you're gonna do it Bobby but I'm just
telling you I want to make sure you
don't pull a fast one with me and you
actually give me what the number is
gonna be at the bottom without trying to
make that additional 22 percent to help
you with you know what I'm talking about
I'm not we're trying to group we're
speaking openly here and they'll kind of
look at you and they know what you're
talking about I just want the bottom
line number because I don't want to
renegotiate because I'm gonna go to the
other two and I find notice you're
trying to get a big bit I won't even
follow up with you I'm just gonna tell
my team to follow up with you I'm moving
on to the next one with the level of
credibility and I'm calling everybody
that has the same level of credibility
and experience as you so having said
that before you give me the cost
structure I need you to know I need to
know exactly how many people how much
it's costing me how much it's gonna cost
me beginning and checks one check
check three checks deposit back
protection I want all of it but give me
a final bid act as if it's the final
offer you're giving me I want that
because if we have to negotiate I don't
like to negotiate like that I just move
on to another company fare are we all on
the same page yes great
I'll give you a couple days to send me
the cost structure on how much it's
gonna cost for us to move forward I'll
be cut are you comfortable with that we
are excellent it's been great spending
time with you thank you so much that
that that that that and as the ten
questions I ask before hiring a
consulting firm an engineer offer me
counter what if you talk about those are
the ten questions that can save you
eventually tens of millions of dollars
so a couple challenges I've got for you
one is if you are not an executive
co-founder maybe you're just an employee
in a company you're trying to come up
share this video with the executives
that you work with because there's gonna
be something here that they're gonna
pick up before hiring the consulting
from on the complete opposite side if
you are a CEO or a founder I want you to
share this video with the consultants
that did it right and say hey this guy
talks about consultants like you because
you guys did alright when we hired you
so give them credibility for them doing
it the right way if there's a place to
write a positive review about great
consultants go post it all over the
place we don't recognize great
consultants enough there's too many bad
ones but the great ones we got to make
sure the world knows about it so they
keep getting better two videos I want
you to watch one is ten decisions you
need to make as a founder click on a
thumbnail here if it doesn't work on the
description the link will be there the
other one is also how to increase the
value of your company if the thumbnail
doesn't work click on a link go to go
watch it question starts comment below
if you haven't subscribed to their
number one channel on YouTube for
entrepreneurs where you will not find
free content like this click on the
subscribe button right here take
everybody